*Playing holst the planets mars*
Top 10...
Videos
My favourite content,
on ALL of Youtube!
Where else could I possibly know,
what the TOP 10 SECRET YOUTUBE TALENTS are?
Where else could I know,
what the f- TOP 5 YOUTUBERS WHO DESTROYED THEIR PLAYBUTTON...
How else can I find the TOP 5 YOUTUBERS WHO CAUGHT GHOSTS IN THEIR VIDEOS?!
*Heavenly Music*
Thank God
For Top 10 Videos
*Cringy YouTuber* Counting down the Top 5
Richest Youtubers-
Hey everybody!
*Alien Noises*
Today we gonna talk about,
Uh
The Top 5 YooToobers
That....
Didn't...
Suck dick for views. *eh, you don't?*
Hey everybody!
Today we are gonna talk about the Top 10,
YooToobers
that
DON'T LIKE CHEESEBURGERS!
How's it going everyone!
Today we are gonna talk about the
Top 10
Male YouTubers that look hot in bikinis. *pewds*
Today we are gonna talk about the Top 10 YooToober haircuts.
*jumpscare*
And it's all clickbait as well
You know fair enough...
ahahahahahahahahahahaha
I may clickbait a little bit
But it's like "Top 10 most expensive YouTube Supercars"
And then there's me in the fucking thing,
and he is like,
implying that that's my car,
When I don't- when I drive a fucking shitty Mini
I need to buy a new car I know but
like, I genuinly have not much interest in cars,
and you're using MY FUCKING NAME
and likeness
FOR THIS SHIT?!
Alright today we're gonna review some of my...
Top
TOP
TOP 10
Shittiest Top 10 lists.
That involve me though,
There are, trust me, there's some,
There is way worse.
And I want to point out they,
They've all been kind of nice to me,
so I don't want to shit completely on them,
you know that wouldn't
that wouldn't be fair to me to shit back.
YO what's going on guys
This is Mr. Top 5 and today in this video-
YOOO
WHAT UP GUYS
IT'S MR. FIIIIIVE
TOP
*alien noises*
Top
five
YouTubers that don't listen to country music.
Starting at number one, Zoella.
That bitch doesn't listen to country music.
*chuckle*
Top
SIX
YouTuber
that doesn't like when I stick my finger
up my asshole.
Starting with your boy, Mr. Top 5.
Don't like it, feels weird.
I love this, of course there's one of people who died.
*clap*
Oh, it's not just who died, it's in 2016.
TOP
FIVE
YOUTUBERS
that DIED
AW THEY FUCKING DIED
that's a top 5, top 5 right there
wait, how many died, c'mon
aw, fuck I can't make a top 10 out of that
DAMMIT
Nine
Really?
REALLY
Did you have to make that out of people who died?
Did you have to take the fact that people passed away
and make your fucking top 10 list out of it?
fuck you
*mildly intense intro music*
I like, uh, you know nothing says, uh, tragedy then uh
a giant fucking annotation that says "click this button this button to subscribe (it's free).
What is it, 2012?
what the fuck
So what is up guys, my name is Top Extract and
today, we're doing kind of a sad topic-
"This video got copyrighted, I won't make any money"
aw AWW *moan*
*sad music*
NO!
*barf noise*
Can you believe it?
His video that profited out of the death of other people got copyrighted?
AW AINSLEY
Can you believe that?
That's AW what a-
Did you know that THAT'S the real tragedy here?
This shit happens to me all the time, it happens to YouTubers all the time,
the fact that he pointed it out in a video like this is fucking amazing.
"I'm donating my own money to the families"
Yeah, fuck off
Just fuck off
You didn't have to make this video.
So you're telling me that you're reaching out..
to five different families to donate money
to somehow justify the fact that you made a top 5 video out of their death?
Lemme just, lemme just guess how this conversation went.
Hey, it's your boy, uh, pimplyface69
Oh, from YouTube, you don't know me?
Oh, uh, okay well that's...
You don't fucking know me?
So I'm making a top 5 list of people that died on YouTube and I've got great news for you!
Uh, you're son made the list!
Yeah!
Yeah, that's amazing!
You wanna call your husband and tell him too?
Oh, that's fine, I'll wait.
Yeah YEAH he made it, he made the top 5 deaths!
Yeah!
I know, it's a big, big honor.
ha
I know
Oh yeah
big, big news
So anyway, I will be, you know, I didn't make any money off the video.
Yeah, I know, copyright *chuckle*
Yeah, can't use other people's footage *chuckle*
Yeah, it's almost like some other family copyrighted the content and took the money...
No no no, so I'll donate anyway because I didn't ma-
I know, I'm a saint.
I'm donating anyway.
So, just send me your Paypal account
uh, Western Union
I'll be donating, you're taken care of.
So what is up guys, my name is Top Extract and today we're doing kind of a sad topic.
I didn't guess that based on the sad music. (there was no sad music)
The sad piano really sold it for me
oh
Today, we're doing kind of a sad topic.
*intense sad music*
What is up guys, my name is Top Extract and today we're doing kind of a sad topic.
ohh
So sad
Now, you might be asking why I'm doing this video-
Yes, I am and I would love your answer.
It's for a couple of reasons-
Okay, a couple of reasons, great, let's hear them.
So, reason number one-
Ad sense
There are actually some really smaller YouTubers that you guys have definitely not heard about
that have, unfortunately, passed away during 2016.
So this video is for those guys and to give back to those families because
out of all the revenue I'm getting from this video,
I'm gonna donate it straight to those families that were affected.
Just don't make the video.
If you want to make a positive cause for these families that lost someone tragically,
there are better ways to go about it then a fu-, ya know
I can't tell you why, maybe like a GoFundMe or some shit
but a Top 5 video...
That doesn't go top 5 on my top 5 best ways to go about someone tragically dying in 2016, all right.
And I just want to help out, pretty much
because out of every sad situation, something nice should happen.
And I think this should be our way of giving back to those people.
At least I know when I die, I'm gonna make it to the top 5 YouTubers who died list.
And I can't wait for, uh
For this guy to contact my family and just say
"Hey..."
"I got you."
It's so fucking stupid, the fact that this video doesn't have more dislikes
To me, it's fucking beyond me.
There's also Top 10 YouTubers who were MURDERED
Hey guys, what's up it's John here and a new microphone and today we're gonna be-
HE'S GOT A NEW MICROPHONE
YES
I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR HIM
*groan*
FINALLY
It must have been that other top 10 murder list that really got it.
Looking at 10 YouTubers who were murdered.
We're gonna be looking at people who were killed because of their YouTube videos
and some other YouTubers who were killed by other reasons.
This list is pretty sad, but I'm gonna try and present it in the most sensitive way possible.
Yeah, I can tell by the tone of your fucking voice.
*happy music*
Hey, guys!
This video is pretty sad!
Here are videos from some of the channels, but a lot of them have been deleted.
Please drop a like if you enjoyed, let's aim for 2,000 likes on this video.
There's just no shame in these fucking people...
*chuckle*
How can you make a top 10 list and start it off with
"I got a new microphone"
and "Remember to hit 'like'"
haha
"Let's get 2,000!!"
Alright, now let's get into number 10
And how do you rank people's deaths?
Think about that concept for a second.
You're basically saying well, Keith Ratliff died, but it wasn't as important
as, you know, Christina Grimmie.
Do you guys think I'd be at #1 on a top 10?
Yeah?
Think it'd be tragic?
Maybe I'd go in a real tragic way so I get #1.
Sure, jeez, I sure hope I get #1.
This whole thing just bums me out.
10 everyday things you need to stop doing
Your fucking channel
How about we start with that.
And I know you might justify these videos as in the sense like
"oh, well there's no ads on it so I'm not making any ad sense"
And people saying,
"oh, I have ads on it, but I'm gonna donate it to the families"
Ad sense doesn't stop, it's something that you keep collecting depending more views.
Are you telling me that you're constantly donating money to these families
based on, ya know, every month you get more ad revenue from the video?
I sincerely doubt it.
And if you're saying that
"ok, well, you know what"
Even if you're justifying it in a way that's like
"ok well I don't have ads on the video so I'm not gaining anything personally from it"
Yeah you fucking do.
If you get 60 millions views on your video, people are gonna click on more of your videos
or subscribe to your channel because they found your content.
fuck me
This is so incredibly dumb.
Anyway guys
This video doesn't have any ads on it so
I'm not benefiting from criticizing these...
top 10 list videos that are not benefiting from anything.
And if you see ads on the video
ha ha ha
That's, uhh
That's a glitch.
That's definitely a glitch.
And, um
uhh
ya know
Scarce here
Pewdiepie out
This is pretty newsworthy
uh
Calling out everyone
Pewdiepie